did that one TVA agent's voice sound
creepily familiar on the second season
premiere of Loki if it did you're
probably a Call of Duty fan here's how
you may know him minor spoilers for Loki
season 2 episode 1 ahead most everyone
knows that Marvel's Disney plus original
series Loki Stars Tom hson is the
title's trickster God of Norse mythology
complete with shiny hair and an
irrepressible need to be the snarkiest
person in the room plenty of members of
the supporting casts are quite well
known as well such as Owen Wilson and
gooo and bov or the most recent addition
to the ensemble Oscar winner Ki Hoy Quan
but not everyone in the cast is an award
winner or top build star at least not
yet for example Neil Ellis a Scottish
actor whose voice might be more famous
than his face on Loki Ellis portrays
Hunter D90 the stick inthe mud minute
man who prunes Wilson's Mobius on the
orders of iMat Ra's Rona Ren Slayer he
changes his tune after he realizes that
every single member of the time variance
Authority is a kidnapped memory wiped
and brainwashed variant stolen from
somewhere on the timeline apparently
it's a lot harder to commit genocide
when you qualify as a potential
candidate for the murder spree yourself
like many Supporting Cast members Ellis
returns for Loki season 2 and has a
delightfully awkward conversation with
Mobius in which he almost but not quite
apologizes for the whole killing him
thing Mobius I was just doing my job
what you mean pruning me yeah well I
guess you're just following orders Ellis
seems to find great success in his
betrayals of soldiers who know how to
follow orders obviously there's Hunter
D90 but there's also Captain John
McTavish better known by code Nam soap
from the Call of Duty video game
franchise Ellis voice is the character
in multiple Modern Warfare entries and
numerous spin-off games outside of these
projects however which he proudly
features at the top of his social media
Pages his resume is relatively sparse
with his only other roles unnamed
background characters before entering
the professional screen and voice acting
business Ellis performed on stage his
education prepared him for Live Theater
he trained at the National Youth Theater
of Great Britain and the Royal Academy
of dramatic arts Shakespeare summer
school yes that means our muscle bound
minute man is a former theater kid he's
also something of an Outdoorsman based
on his love of hiking in the countryside
on top of all that he appears to be a
dedicated Jim bro this is starting to
sound dangerously like a dating profile
bio isn't it in November 2022 Ella sat
down with Dan Allen gaming for an
interview about Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 in support of the Charity's
game on cancer and Call of Duty
endowment while he's proud of his
Scottish Heritage his Instagram bio
Sports the Scottish galic praise for
Scotland forever it appears that his
natural Scottish accent wasn't quite
Scottish enough for soap so he ramped it
up to make the character's Glasgow
Origins more believable like any accent
from any country some accents are going
to be thicker than others Ellis's
Scottish accent is entirely absent on
Loki though the best description of
Hunter d90s voice is Angry American
monotone looks like your favorite Loki
betrayed you mobus most of the time he
doesn't speak at all he just stares in
Moody silence even getting to the point
where he could half apologized to Mobius
must have exerted every ounce of his
willpower but hey that's growth maybe
he'll get more time and season 2 to
squeeze out the other half of that
apology Marvel's Loki season 2 is
streaming now with new episodes hitting
Disney plus every Thursday through
November 9th